Look out! Here come the Spider-Men.
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse" was the first
theatrical movie to crack open the concept of the
multiverse for Spider-Man. The MCU's live-action
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" is following in those
footsteps in a lot of ways, bringing in characters
from other universes — bad guys, and good guys.
Alright, let's get this out of the way
— yes, Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire
are in this movie in the roles of
Peter Parker, and Peter Parker.
"You're not Peter Parker."
Bringing together three different
Spider-Men makes for a smaller version of the
Spider-Verse to manifest on the big screen.
It also leaves room for the possibility that other
Spider-Man variants can enter the picture down the
road. We know there's plenty of them.
"Wherever I go, the wind follows — and
the wind smells like rain."
However, there is one face that
fans undoubtedly will expect to show up sooner
rather than later, and that's Miles Morales.
He's already led his own flick in the animated
hit "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse," which
will soon have a pair of sequels to its name.
So when will he make the leap to live-action?
If a certain "No Way Home" Easter egg is any
indication, it could be right around the corner.
"They're starting to come
through, and I can't stop them."
Miles Morales may not physically appear in
"Spider-Man: No Way Home," but it's made
abundantly clear that audiences aren't
the only ones expecting him to pop up.
At the end of the climactic battle, Andrew
Garfield's Peter Parker reveals his face
to his Amazing Spider-Man 2 nemesis, Electro.
After the unmasking, Electro seems disappointed,
remarking that because the hero was from Queens,
had a cool costume, and always helped out poor
people, he was expecting Spider-Man to be Black.
Electro's surprise shouldn't be too, er, shocking,
because the villain has never seen the face
of his nemesis before this interaction.
It's a humorous moment, but fans of the
comic books or "Into the Spider-Verse"
know there's more to this line than meets
the eye. There is, of course, at least one
Black Spider-Man -- Miles Morales -- and while he
hasn't appeared in the MCU yet as a live-action
hero, it's clear the seeds are being planted
for him to show up at some point in the future.
This is far from the first time
Miles has been referenced in the MCU.
In "Spider-Man: Homecoming," Tom Holland's
Spider-Man meets Aaron Davis, who is Miles
Morales' uncle within the Marvel canon. (He and
his alter-ego the Prowler previously appeared
outside of the MCU in "Into the Spider-Verse.")
At one point during their "Homecoming"
interaction, Aaron even mentions having a
nephew – though he doesn't mention him by name.
"The other night, you told that dude, 'If you're
gonna shoot somebody, shoot me.' That's pretty
ballsy. I don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood. I got a nephew who live here."
Hopefully, the next time the Spider-Verse comes
into play in the MCU, Miles can get in on the
action. With another MCU "Spider-Man"
trilogy on the way, there's more than
enough room for another Spidey in this universe.
"I thought I was the only one. You're like me."
"I don't want to be."
"I don't think you have a choice, kiddo."
As we wait for Miles Morales to make his
way into the MCU, some are wondering:
is there another way we might see Tom Holland's
Peter Parker take on Miles as a protege? Maybe!
In an interview with SyFy Wire, Tom Holland
was asked if he would ever consider joining the
animated "Into the Spider-Verse" franchise.
His response was clear:
"Love them, and I'm just
waiting for the phone call."
While it may seem like a pipe dream to get
an MCU star into a purely Sony project,
Holland revealed that there have been talks
behind the scenes about getting him into the
Spider-Verse one way or another. He revealed,
"[Spider-Verse producer] Amy [Pascal] actually
asked me on the set of this movie,
and no one has come back to me."
Could such a cameo end up in the upcoming "Across
the Spider-Verse (Part One)" or "Two?" Perhaps!
Judging from the trailer, Miles Morales actually
steps outside of his own reality this time around,
travelling through worlds beyond his
own. It's possible Miles could enter
a live-action sphere at some point, briefly
meeting Tom Holland's variant to say, "Hello."
Or perhaps Tom Holland's Spider-Man will
enter Miles's reality and become animated for
a brief period of time. However it transpires,
Electro's wish has already come true: there is
a Black Spider-Man, and he'll be web-slinging
his way onto your screens for years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.